EVERYWHERE.
SEEMS LIKE IT WILL BE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT DYNAMIC IN
TERMS OF THE PROSECUTION.
>> JESSE, WHAT GOOD IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF
REGULATIONS IF THIS CAN HAPPEN
TO PEOPLE?
LACKS TIME HE APPEARED BEFORE
MAXINE WATERS' COMMITTEE SHE
APPEARED TO BLOW HIM A KISS.
>> SHE DIDN'T APPEAR TO.
SHE DID.
I SAW IT.
SHE BLEW A KISS.
THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD TO PUT OUT THIS FIRE,
BECAUSE THIS GUY WAS ON A REHAB
TOUR.
EVERY TIME HE OPENED HIS MOUTH
HE WAS HUMILIATING THE
DEMOCRATS.
HE WAS HUMILIATING BILL CLINTON,
THE IRS, WALL STREET, THE SEC.
EVERYBODY WAS IN BED WITH THIS
GUY.
FOR A MONTH AND A HALF HE WENT
OUT AND TALKED MORE THAN FAUCI
AND EXPOSED THE CODE.
THE CODE IS I'M GOING TO SAY
WHATEVER THE LEFT WANTS TO HEAR
AND I'M GOING TO SHOVEL MONEY
DOWN THEIR THROAT.
SO THEY LET ME DO WHAT I WANT.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK
ABOUT THE CODE.
IT'S A SILENT CODE.
IT'S CALLED GREEN WASHING, WOKE
WASHING, WHATEVER YOU CALL IT,
AND THAT BLOWS UP THE WHOLE
SYSTEM.
IT'S LIKE BRIBERY, GREASING
POLITICIANS, BUT HE PUT IT OUT
THERE WAY TOO GRAPHICALLY.
SO HE HAD TO GO DOWN.
HE STOLE MONEY FROM PEOPLE, AND
THEN HE DONATED IT TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO BIDEN HAD TO BUST HIS SECOND
BIGGEST MEGADONOR.
IT WAS A PUMP AND DUMP.
HE WAS PUMPING AND DUMPING.
THE DEMOCRATS PUMPED AND DUMPED
HIM.
THEY LEGITIMATIZED HIM.
HE'S GOT HIS COMPANY'S NAME ON
ARENAS, UP THERE WITH BILL AND
CELEBRITIES NOW.
THERE'S COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
HE WENT DOWN HARD.
YOU CAN SEE THIS FRAUD A MILE
AWAY.
GREG AND I TALK ABOUT THIS ALL
THE TIME, WHETHER IT'S AVENATTI,
SAMMIE STICKY FINGERS, PINCHING
BAGS AT EVERY AIRPORT IN THE
NATION.
IT'S A BIG ADVERTISEMENT FOR
SCAM ARTISTS.
WE SEE IT, BUT YOU CAN'T SAY IT.
IF YOU SAY IT, YOU'RE A BIGOT.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
THEN THE LEFT, THEY DON'T WANT
TO HEAR IT, BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING RICH OFF OF IT.
THEY'RE GETTING, YOU KNOW, GOOD
PRESS OFF OF IT.
SO WHATEVER.
NOW HE WANTS TO GET OUT OF
PRISON BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GIVING HIM A VEGAN DIET.
>> YEAH.
>> LISTEN, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
GET YOUR BAIL REDUCED.
HE'S A FLIGHT RISK ALREADY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE COLON CANCER,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BECAUSE YOU
DON'T LIKE THE FOOD, SORRY, YOU
HAVE TO STAY IN JAIL WITH SOME
BAHAMIAN KNUCKLEHEADS.
>> JUST TWO WEEKS AGO HE WAS IN
FRONT OF A BIG "NEW YORK TIMES"
AUDIENCE BEING INTERVIEWED, AND
THE AUDIENCE WAS LAUGHING WHEN
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WAS MAKING
JOKES ABOUT, OH, MAYBE MY LAWYER
SAID I SHOULDN'T DO THIS.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS SO FUNNY.
>> HOW QUICKLY THE TIDE HAS
TURNED, DANA.
>> RED TIDE.
>> GIVE HIM LONG PANTS.
I'VE SEEN HIS KNEES MORE THAN
I'VE SEEN MY OWN.
THESE BIG MEATY HOOKS, SITTING
THERE WITH SHORTS.
HE'S SLIGHTLY BETTER DRESSED
THAN JOHN FETTERMAN, BUT I WON'T
GO THAT FAR.
THE TIMING IS SUSPICIOUS.
YOU KNOW, BEFORE HE SINGS, HE
GETS ARRESTED.
IF HE ENDS UP DEAD IN JAIL WE'LL
KNOW ONE THING, THAT HE
DEFINITELY SWINDLED HILLARY
CLINTON.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE THESE RED
FLAGS.
ONE OF THE RED FLAGS, I'M SORRY,
WE GOT TO TALK ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
LOOK.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU CAN JUDGE A BOOK BY ITS
COVER.
YOU BROUGHT UP SAM BRYNTON.
HE HAD THE VOICE OF A CREEPY
WIND-UP DOLL.
HE LOOKS LIKE ONE OF THE
FORGOTTEN THREE STOOGES.
IF HE TRANSITIONS, PERHAPS HE
COULD BE ON "THE VIEW."
IT'S A LESSON, REITERATING WHAT
YOU SAID, IT'S A LESSON FOR
EVERYONE.
THE CELEBRITIES GET SUED?
THEY SHOULD.
THEY PUSHED IT.
>> TOM BRADY?
>> EXCEPT FOR TOM BRADY, BECAUSE
HE'S AN AMERICAN HERO.
BUT ANYWAY, COMPASSIONATE
INVESTING IS USUALLY A CYNICAL
COVER.
REPUBLICANS FALL FOR THIS LESS
THAN DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE WE --
YOU CAN'T SUCKER PEOPLE THAT
KNOW ECONOMICS INTO A BAD DEAL.
I WON'T EVEN BE TRICKED INTO A
GOOD DEAL.
LIKE I'M STILL NOT DOING THE
401(K) UNTIL I SEE SOME REAL
RESULTS.
>> YOUR MATTRESS MUST BE